listen if there's one thing I can tell
you as I see a lot of people that don't
grow past a certain level because they
have certain inner insecurities that
nobody knows about let me explain to you
what insecurities are to you you ever
have that one dream the nightmare that
you read about in these dream books and
this nightmare is the one that you know
this bad guys coming after you and no
matter how much you try to move you
can't even move you know what you want
I'm telling you like you're trying to
run your legs don't move it's almost
that's it they're glued to the ground
right you know you know what I'm saying
you ever had that nightmare before so
your insecurities are the glue if you
don't address your insecurities you
don't feel you can get away from the
nightmare and live your dreams in this
episode I'm gonna speak to you about the
different kind of insecurities we all
have and how to address them so you know
a lot of times we see somebody that's
very successful and so oh my gosh this
guy must have zero insecurities he must
be a hundred percent confident look at
the way he talks here's a reality of it
there's not a single person in the world
that doesn't have any insecurities even
the best-looking Brad Pitt Ryan Gosling
whatever these actresses that you see
Margot Robbie they all have certain
insecurities as a matter of fact here's
a weird thing to be thinking about over
the years I've met a lot of beautiful
woman some of the most insecure woman I
met in my life were the hottest ones and
by the way a party with a lot of guys is
what we would go out and get with them
some of the most insecure men I've ever
met with the best-looking ones with
beautiful bodies nice faces and they
were still insecure there's a formula
for it if you don't address it these
things can haunt you and you can't even
enjoy your life I'm going to talk about
two different kinds of insecurities and
they 8-step process on how to address
your insecurities in this video so first
of all let's address the two different
kinds of insecurities that you may have
some of them are going to be physical
and some of them are going to be
emotional believe it or not we think
it's the physical ones that have the
most consequences in our lives but it's
actually the emotional ones so let's
have some fun person talk about the
physical ones
alright so quick disclaimer before I get
into this physical stuff some of them I
say is gonna make you feel uncomfortable
because it has to do with you so if
you're ready I can go into it so take a
deep breath
let it out and just brace yourself
here's some of the physical things that
most of us are insecure with hands some
people don't like the size of their
hands stretch mark I do gain a lot of
weight or you lost a lot of weight but
you can get them on your chest your
thighs your legs people don't like them
knows a lot of people don't like the
fact that they have a big nose I used to
have a very big nose because I was very
skinny so it looked even bigger it was
something I struggled with when I was in
high school your skin your skin tone
acne some people don't like their skin
some people don't like the color of
their skin they wish they were wider
they wish it were dark body hair some
people have a lot of body here wrinkles
some people don't like the wrinkles on
their face private parts both men and
women listen breasts butt or your
dangling there are some people that are
very uncomfortable about their private
parts yes I said dangling body orders
and other ones some people smell funny
so I wish I smelled it from people have
told me I smell funny
teeth I have that one tooth right in the
bottom there that's crooked I wish it
was straight right toes man one of my
toes is longer than the other one I'm
embarrassed when I worried those open
toes I wish that toe wasn't longer can't
I just chop it up just cut it off
already right my weight man I'm too
skinny I'm too fat I wish I was 50
pounds lighter man my height I'm too
tall I don't fit anywhere and I'm too
short I wish I was a little bit taller
right baldness I don't like this bald
stuff man I know people say it's sexy I
wish I had a hair got hairline you know
that hair let's keep going back and
forth
I know LeBron James has a hairline this
one but man I don't like my hairline I
wish I didn't have a hairline shoe size
why am i size six man I wish I was a
size 13 or 16 I was Shaq Shaq a size 24
what if I had feet that big okay so you
okay did you is you still taking a deep
breath or you just laughing all over the
place you're still thinking about the
private part stuff I talked about by the
way everybody has one of those right
there you thought about okay as funny
and as true as this maybe this is not
even close to what's really holding you
back it's the emotional stuff so let's
get into the emotional stuff so one of
them is your upbringing listen to what
you were raised maybe you're not happy
with the fact that you were raised in a
trailer home or you're not happy about
the fact that you grew up in a certain
city there were gangs maybe you don't
like the way your parents raised you
your mom or your dad you
that abuse your mom abused you you know
your mom embarrasses you sometimes
because of the fault she made a mistake
she made your dad the same way it's
maybe your friends maybe you're not
proud of your friends maybe you're not
proud of the fact that you don't have
friends
maybe you think all your friends are
having fun they don't even want to be
around you right maybe your spouse
you're not happy with the person your
mirror maybe you don't even have a
spouse you wish you had a spouse
everybody else has a boyfriend everybody
else has a girlfriend but you don't and
you feel maybe I'm not good enough you
know maybe I'm not good enough for
somebody your kids your family your
nationality I wish I was white I wish I
was Hispanic I wish I was black you wish
you were something else your past you
did some stuff in the past year
embarrass them you have some past
failures a bad breakup a bad divorce a
past mistake that is absolutely
embarrassing that if people found out
about it you'd want to find the smallest
hole and go hide in it right
social anxiety from not wanting to be
around a lot of people you'd like to be
by yourself you're afraid when there's a
lot of people there's a big crowd maybe
you remember certain words set to you by
your loved ones maybe your mom dad
husband wife ex any of that some of
these things maybe you relate to
somebody told you you're stupid you're
ugly you're short you're slow you're
worthless you're fat no one will ever
love you no one would ever marry you
you'll never amount to anything you'll
never be able to stop drinking you'll
never be anything in your life maybe it
isn't some of the words maybe you had
somebody in your life that was a
perfection as a father a mother that
wanted you to win and do everything
right maybe you had a coach a boss
somebody that expected so much from you
you feel like you can't move because
your standards are perfection you feel
like you have to do everything perfectly
right or else you're not worth it these
are some of the things that people
struggle with on the emotional side
maybe even you're watching this right
now you're telling yourself man these
are some of the things I've dealt with
and let me tell you hurts me it's it's
it scarred me it's difficult to even
listen to it I understand but you are
not alone we all have them we all have
physical we all have emotional you have
to sit down at one point and address
them in order to put it behind you so
you can move on and live the life that
you want to live so if you're listening
to this stuff and you tell them you said
Pat this is painful man I relate to some
of this stuff yeah that hurt me my mom
did say something like that my dad did
say something like that I I feel like
you have to be perfect I
you don't know the way I was raised I
understand here's the reality I have
insecurities some are physical some are
emotional you have insecurities some are
physical some are emotional no one's
gonna be insecurity 100% free everyone's
gonna have a little bit of it but you
got address it and if you keep hiding it
and not addressing it life ain't gonna
change much for you so hopefully in this
video you're actually gonna follow some
of these formulas that I'm gonna give to
you and start questions some of these
things and see if we can get rid of some
of them fix some of them fair enough
having said that let's get to the next
part of this video number one so you
just heard me make a list of
insecurities both physical and emotional
some of you may say well I relate to
this one a little bit of this for me all
this other stuff no matter what it is
that you have the first thing you need
to do to address your insecurities is
actually make a list of them literally
make a list of them I've been told I'm
ugly I've been told I'm short I've been
taught whatever it is make a list your
list write them down okay once you do
that you got to ask yourself three
questions about each one of them here's
how simple the questions are number one
is it true number two is it partially
true number three is it absolutely wrong
okay once you answer that about each one
of them then you have the next thing to
answer okay here's what the next thing
is can I permanently fix it - can i
partially improve it three there's
nothing I can do about it for instance
you've been told you have bad skin so
you say yes it's partially true can you
do anything about it
yes I can improve it but I can't
permanently get rid of it great now you
have something that you can improve but
if somebody tells you I've been told I'm
short okay how tall are you
five three can you improve your height
no that's not changing okay number two
you have to make a list of the
insecurities that you cannot change and
you have to accept yourself newsflash
you are gonna have some things in your
body and your height and your emotional
side that there's nothing you can do
about period there are certain things
physically you're not gonna be able to
change maybe you're bald you can have
plants per height you can do nothing
about shoe size you can do nothing about
hand size you can't do nothing about
there are a lot of things you can do
nothing about and sometimes the biggest
challenge is to be able to address that
and say listen I have to accept this
it's fine
everybody's born with certain flaws and
certain insecurities I'm moving on
that's step number two number three okay
so if you're saying well Pat now I have
a hard time accepting some of these you
got to do them because number three
isn't any easier either number three is
forgiveness and here's what I mean by
forgiveness I'm not trying to be the
spiritual leader for you and get up
you're saying you got to forgive I'm not
it's not the easy the easiest thing to
do a lot it's a very hard to do but
you're not necessarily forgiving for the
other person you're forgiving for
yourself you have to understand that
your parents are not perfect you don't
know what your mom and dad were going
through that day when they told you what
they were telling you you have no idea
what your ex was going through maybe
they were hurting a lot of times you
hear the saying the person that's
hurting is hurting right the person who
hurts is hurting like internally you
don't know what that person is going
through so you have to yourself and
listen and I forgive him I forgive her
it's all good I'm gonna move on why
because one day you're gonna help
somebody forgives you as well so step
number three is actually telling
yourself I am willing to forgive this
individual number four so listen the
next one may sound hokey too but it
works and that's your affirmations daily
affirmations the other day I was in the
garage and I was going through a bunch
of different things I found these boxes
and all of a sudden I found one of these
boxes I said wait a minute what is this
year this is my affirmation from 2002
you can see all the blemishes on the
side this was on my shower wall and I
would read it non-stop
loud all the time you know why
affirmations are necessary for some
people you ever hear some people that
are very confident comfortable in their
skin and they'll say things like oh when
I was you know growing up my mother told
me how amazing I was she loved me my dad
loved me and even some motivational
speakers will say my parents love me my
mother loved me
that's not everybody not every culture
is like that and not everybody had a
parent that raised them that way right
if you don't you need to have some
information these are some of the ones
ahead look look at the last one that I
have here by the way here's the last one
that I have don't you want to retire
your dad buy yourself a house become
debt-free make this story builders it's
the first company I've ever built was in
2001 make the story builders a company
and I made the biggest difference and
become a great example to others who are
model you build the best school in the
country where the students learn to
become great leaders at a younger age I
wrote this in 2001 drive your Ferrari go
visit your horses at the stable have a
bunch of pets at your house have a
beautiful white tiger great family great
spirits your life many kids and be able
to live all your dreams then you gotta
get off your ass and get after that's my
last affirmation by the way every one of
them had to do with something had to
work on at that time every one of my
affirmations here's another one that I
created I create this in 2007 2008 I
will personally do my best to make all
decisions with the core foundation of
integrity when making decisions keep
this in mind emotions high intelligence
low number to focus on my strengths
rather than my weaknesses number three
not be afraid of taking a risk and
facing my fears number four embrace
confrontation and adversity rather than
ignoring it number five share my vision
with the people around me at all times I
mean you get the idea these are things
that matter to me at that point of my
life - your affirmations change as you
grow up into next level of your life the
next ones that I have right now is two
three pages it's completely different
than this one or this one
but affirmations work stop putting it
aside and letting all the other hokey
people do it and let their dreams become
a reality rather you test it for you and
see how it works I promise you your from
now you won't recognize yourself number
five all right here's another one that's
pretty simple and it's effective you've
heard a million different time but you
got to do and that's gratitude you got
to sit and make a list of things you're
grateful for literally take the sheet of
paper and make a list of things you're
grateful for a family mom dad live in
America live in my country I live 30
minutes away from the beach whatever it
is when you make a list every single
time you do this exercise no matter how
much insecurities you have and how many
fears you're having how many concerns
you're having somehow someway this
exercise about gratitude always gives
you peace number six so look the next
thing you got to do is you got to figure
out a way to increase your internal
value what do I mean by internal value
as hot as you may be right now you ain't
gonna be hot like this would arrest your
life you can be a 75 year old
good-looking person still for a 75 year
old but a 75 year old isn't gonna be
better looking than a 22 year old
good-looking person right however a 75
year old would a lot of internal value
is emotionally attractive to the world
so work on increasing
your internal value what do I mean by
this they are typically you've heard of
Maslow's law where he says all these
different needs you have you have a need
for this you have a need for that let me
just simplify in a basic way for you to
be thinking about it we have a law we
have a need for connection we have a
need for connection what do I mean by
connection love this could be friendship
we need friends we need companions
somebody we build a family with somebody
we build a life with right interaction
we need that there's a need for that
another one that you need is a career
like I am valuable I am valuable in a
marketplace I know how to do XYZ and
people count on me to do XYZ that
increases my value because I'm an expert
in an area right then there is spiritual
value that you increase spiritual value
whatever your faith may be right it
could be a religion it could be a prayer
it could be meditation it could be a
complete different thing but you got to
have spiritual why see this right here
with your friends family loved ones this
is human or action you're with them your
career you're with people spiritual you
got to figure out a way to get along
with yourself when your friends and
family are not Iran and when your
co-workers are not around that's
spiritual connection there's got to be a
game plan for that if you don't have
that and you always have to be around
people to be happening you have the
sense of insecurity you're generally not
going to be at peace for too long so
what could be the game plan you may say
Pat how can I have a game plan for
friends family and loved ones very
simple have a game plan what do you want
to look for in a spouse actually be
clear about what you want right and who
do I have to be to get this partner who
do I have to be to have a partner and
have a connection like this what kind of
friends do you want to have what kind of
friends do I need to be to have a friend
like that you got to go through that
process on this site of connection with
people where do I need to put myself
maybe I'm too timid maybe I put myself
maybe I need to start talking to people
I don't talk a lot I don't ask questions
I'm just so shy and make other people
may feel uncomfortable so maybe I want
to start asking people more questions
and getting to know them and put myself
out there but there's got to be a game
plan here the other side Currier wise I
have a career but I'm not really playing
that much often so what do you need to
put yourself out there maybe you need to
learn three more new skills may need to
be a little bit more assertive about
yourself and next time somebody says who
wants to take this responsibility I'll
try put your
self out there put yourself out there
where someone's gonna say this guy came
through she came through but you're
improving also on your career side
spiritual side start seeking read some
books read some spiritual books maybe
pick up a book that talks about every
single one of the religions and see what
makes sense to you talk about it a
little bit pray about it and meditate
about it go take yoga I don't know
but have a game plan for each one of
these things to advance in your life
because when you do that you increase
your value internally and slowly but
surely you start becoming more and more
confident and your insecurities go away
number seven so we just talked about it
you got to figure out a way to increase
your value internally right you also got
to figure out a way to increase your
value externally what do I mean by that
you got skin issues put a game plan go
sit with somebody and see what they're
gonna tell you about improving your skin
you're out of shape get in shape you
don't feel good about the way you look
do so you don't like the way you dress
figure out a way how to dress maybe go
talk to somebody read books on it but
somehow someway also try to figure out a
way maybe you're not physically gonna be
a ten I mean in reality who is a ten
maybe you're currently a four but you
can at least take yourself to seven and
a half what's that game plan figure out
a way to improve your diet your health
your life your exercise your energy all
of that stuff so put a game plan also
for external value number eight okay so
the last thing you got to do is not an
easy one to do and that's why I left the
last here's what it is you got to sit
together with the trusted mentor who's
not afraid of telling you the truth not
a jerk but it's not afraid of telling
the truth it's not afraid of telling
you're full of it
they're not afraid of telling you you're
overthinking it they're not afraid of
telling you why are you worried about
this they're not afraid of telling you
listen you you think you're good in this
you're really not don't think too much
about this it's okay this is the area
you want improving but you need somebody
to sit with that's a trusted mentor that
understands your insecurities that's
willing to be gentle with you yet is
willing to be honest with you
and from there you walk out and you say
wow this is great I got a game plan to
go out there and address my insecurities
and that whole nightmare thing I told
you about will you glue because your
insecurities you can finally remove your
legs and run away and go live the dream
life that you want to live alright so by
the way I've had so many different
private conversations about people with
their insecurities to address what they
need to do to take their games to the
next level so I do know if you're
touching this and if you actually watch
this video again after downloading the
PDF that Mario made for you you click on
a link below in the description go get
the PDF watch it again take inventory
and improve it because if you just set
the society and you watch it one time
ain't gonna have a lot of effect on your
second thing we just cross 900,000 subs
thank you so much everybody all the
value Tanner's out there I am so I
respect you so much because I think
value tainment fans are the best fans in
the world because they want to improve
and get better and make the economy the
world a better place so much respect for
you you don't just come here for
entertainment you come here because you
want to improve I respect you and cannot
wait to meet you at our first live value
teaming conference when we cross a
million subs we're this close by the way
very very close last but not least
thoughts comments comment below if you
haven't subscribed to the channel do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
love you yes I said bangle Inc you're
gonna put a banana you're gonna put a
banana with like two oranges yes you're
gonna say Peggy said dangling